nato's new strategic concept the
alliance says it's facing new challenges
and has decided to adopt a fundamental
shift in deterrence and defense
but will this new concept work and will
make nato countries safer this is inside
story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm hashem
russia is the most direct and
significant threat to peace and security
in the western world
that's nato's latest security assessment
of moscow
it was disclosed during a crucial summit
in madrid the alliance's members
endorsed a more aggressive stance than
the last time they agreed on strategy in
2010
more troops more funding and more
support for each other
russia accused nato of acting with
imperial ambitions and using ukraine to
assert its power
nato says it's facing a more dangerous
and competitive world as it presented
his strategy at the summit
the alliance promised more troops in
europe and declared an unshakable
long-term commitment to ukraine
as part of that president joe biden
announced a permanent u.s army base in
poland and additional land air and sea
deployments across europe the u.s will
also send two more f-35 fighter jet
squadrons to the uk
sweden and finland were invited to join
nato during the summit marking historic
shift in european security
and nato said it continues to view its
nuclear arsenal as a deterrent only
while reiterating its commitment to the
non-proliferation treaty
for the first time nato leaders voice
concern about the threat they see china
posing in the future
china is
substantially building up its military
forces
including nuclear weapons
bullying its neighbors and threatening
taiwan
investing heavily in critical
infrastructure
including in allied countries
monitoring and controlling its
own citizens to advance technology
and spreading
russian lies and disinformation
china is not our adversary
but we must be clear-eyed about the
serious challenges it represents
russia's president vladimir putin says
he is not opposed to finland and sweden
joining nato but he warned moscow would
respond to any deployments in countries
that could pose a threat
uh
there's nothing that might concern us in
terms of finland and sweden becoming
nato members if they want to please go
ahead but they should clearly understand
that they didn't face any threats before
this now if nato troops and
infrastructure are deployed we will be
compelled to respond in kind and create
the same threats to the territory that
is now creating threats for us it's
obvious what they don't understand that
everything was going fine between us but
now there will be tensions this is
obvious and inevitable i repeat if they
pose a threat to us
let's bring in our guests in moscow
vladimir sotnikov director at russia
east west center for strategic studies
and analysis in brussels teresa fallon
is director
of the center for russia-europe asia
studies and in hong kong andrew lung is
china affairs analyst and chairman of
andrew long international consultants
welcome to the program
vladimir the new strategic concept
embraced by nato does it reinforce the
sentiment among the russians that nato
remains an existential threat for their
country
yes by all means actually and that was
the not the moscow choice because nato
actually is not like it was in 2010
when there was a summit uh of nato
countries and then uh at that time
russia was named as a partner so that
the uh the the present uh summit at
madrid to somehow could be called
historic because to my mind this is a
evident turn to the new cold war and in
this cold war actually the west and the
nato countries are the direct and
imminent threat to russia's security
teresa you get a sense in the new
blueprint
that the nato that nato is pretty much
concerned not only about russia but also
about the potential of a chinese
military cooperation with russia in the
near future and this explains why they
are adding china as a
security challenge for
the alliance
yes the language is systemic challenge
and i think there is a lot of
negotiation among the members on exactly
what type of language to use some
european countries have big investments
in china and they don't want to see
china and russia in the same basket but
i would say that what really clinched it
for many people or countries in central
and eastern europe especially was the
february fourth document signed in
beijing and the run-up to the olympics
where president putin and xi jinping
signed an agreement or a statement with
many points but one of the key points
was that they both were joined together
to push back on nato so i think that
this sent a red flag to many countries
and we've seen a lot of cooperation with
russia and china to those who have been
paying attention it's been taking place
for quite a long time there have been
three recent documents in the last few
years that they signed together plus
we've seen russia-china naval operations
or exercises in the mediterranean in the
the baltics so they've been cooperating
and sending signals to europe
okay andrew i mean
you the the the the alliance has been
saying unequivocally that they consider
china's global ambitions as a threat to
the international liberal architecture
how is this reverberating across china
well this is of course uh nothing new
as far as the united states um
360 degree confrontation with china is
concerned because we sold it
starting
with the trade war under trump
and then intensified
under president biden um technology war
south china sea and so and so forth but
then at the back of it all
um in in fact the near pier competitor
there was a country uh with
neo-peer capabilities in economics and
in the military
in geopolitics uh it's not russia it's
in fact china and then many think tanks
in the united states and the biden
administration have said so so um the
united states would rather
get the war or ukraine over with of
course on their terms and then
concentrate all they have to confront
china because china is now seen as an
existential threat to american hegemony
um for example in the south china sea um
i mean you have reported that a child is
building up its capabilities uh which
can create create a fake company for the
united states before even um the united
states have time to muscle uh enough
response and of course china's
connectivity the greatest strength it is
global connectivity 130 countries around
the world have china as the largest
trading partner compared with only 57
for the united states and then
in the g7 um
the united states and led coalition is
introducing uh this g7 so-called g7 uh
global infrastructural uh projects but
then um it's starting a little bit too
little too late all right vladimir
the war in ukraine has changed dynamics
in the region to the point where we're
talking now about
geopolitical realignments president
biden is saying that the u.s is going to
have permanent
u.s army base in poland
i i assume this would be a nightmare
scenario for russia
well actually i would like to say that
this would be this wouldn't be to my
mind
at my best knowledge
uh the nightmare scenario because uh yes
you're right russia that uh dynamics has
changed but that because uh this is a
conflict this is a military conflict
actually basically and the ground
realities are not just like in the
military books in general academy of
military services
so
i think that russia is ready for that
and what is more important actually that
whatever the outcome of this uh
ukrainian russia-ukrainian conflict
could be i think i'm i'm not i'm not
sure that in this cold war which is
going right after the summit and which
is going uh and then which will be
prolonged after the
finishing of the russia ukrainian armed
conflict that uh in this new realities
in this new cold war i'm not sure that
the west will be the victorious side not
just like in post-soviet union when the
gorbachev declared its peristroika
all right
uh teresa if sweden and finland join
nato then the
the alliance will have a thousand three
hundred kilometer border
with
russia this could in itself
be the beginning of an era of a seismic
geopolitical shift that would see russia
grappling with the presence of western
troops just on the border across the
door
let me just pick up first on the
previous point of my colleague who
stated that this is a new cold war
we must remember that russia invaded
ukraine and it was an unprovoked war and
its ongoing war and this has been going
on since 2014. so i think today with
president biden's speech
at the end of the nato summit he he
stated that last year when he met with
president putin he warned him that if he
invaded ukraine that he would see a
united west and an even bigger and
stronger nato so that's exactly what
putin has gotten and when you mentioned
now about sweden and finland we've seen
a reversal of two over two centuries
worth of neutrality from sweden they
have calculated that the situation is so
dire that they need to join nato finland
as you pointed out has a long border
with russia so they have carefully
calculated and they have decided that it
is far better to be with nato than to
end up like ukraine and be invaded and
have the country bombed into rubble so i
think that russia's actions have
actually created exactly what president
putin didn't want he's got a stronger
nato he's got 32 countries now rather
than 30 that somehow you must explain to
his domestic audience that this special
military operation has created all of
this blowback on russia
in addition sanctions are biting in
russia their economy is hurting and
europeans will never be as dependent as
they are today on russian energy they
will it will take some time but over the
next two years they will have to further
diversify and they will no longer be as
reliant on russian energy so this will
also hurt russia in the longer term and
finally
china can just sit back and watch a
reduced and weakened russia this will
help them very much uh they have had had
some difficult times in their past
history with russia so china doesn't
have to do a thing in in many respects
some analysts have said maybe xi jinping
encouraged russia to start this war in
ukraine and so china is actually the
biggest beneficiary here and it's
carefully trying to convince everyone
that it's not really supporting russia
but as we noted earlier these agreements
have shown this but china might be one
of the biggest benefactors or
beneficiaries when it comes to what
happens in the future in the arctic this
is a key area and russia will be
diminished and weakened and china will
drive a hard bargain with russia and may
have more ability to navigate through
the arctic
andrew
as you know historically speaking for
the americans the the first step to do
if you want to counter
uh chinese uh expansion is to go into
the sphere of influence of china itself
and stop it there and don't you see the
invitation of australia south uh korea
japan and new zealand to the uh
alliance summit as a message that the
focus is going to be now on the
indo-pacific region
well there's a talk of course after the
so-called court uh with india um
australia
um and then that comes the recent
idea
of forming
a g-12 of democracies including
even south korea
and to contain china
now
i think that the one has kind of
distinguished between the rhetoric or
the narrative and the reality now as far
as the war on ukraine is concerned
there is an initial uh western
jubilation uh even we really see
president biden and his team uh robbing
their hands in gree uh at the uh the the
russia's uh initial kind of withdrawal
and and and failure uh or of to achieve
any progress but now the situation is
beginning
the same realities begin to sink in
after russia has now
concentrated on dual bats and making
steady gains and then there is a fatigue
setting in in the west as energy prices
food prices increases
inflation fears or even recession fears
are hitting not only
most of the countries in europe but also
back home in the united states affecting
president biden's midterm chances so um
in spite of all the rhetoric you can see
that um there is a lot of wishful
thinking a lot of denial but there is no
doubt that there is a game changer as
far as nato is concerned but
unfortunately modern wars are not bought
by
soldiers and puts on the ground i mean
you have hypersonic weapons you have
missiles you have
cyber warfare
and of course russia is a huge country
it's the largest the world's largest
landmass the largest territory uh well
ahead of the united states the second
largest landmass and it's canada and the
united states comes third no country in
the world in history has ever conquered
russia i mean not even um the nazis uh
and and and not and early on even
napoleon
vladimir yeah what would be the next
step for russia do you see them teaming
up with the chinese along with other
countries to build some sort of a
counter alliance to cope with the
growing expansion of the of nato
eastwards
uh well this is a good question actually
i was thinking it uh to myself and my
point is that my personal uh impression
that this is the moment the crucial
moment for russian foreign policy when
uh the relationship between russia and
nato countries and more generally
between russia and the west probably
has deteriorated for years to come at
least
the new strategic concept of
nato summit in madrid says about the
year of 2030 so at least 2030. so russia
actually is uh
doing a lot of effort
to
combine uh combined strength with its
partners and
allies like like china because china as
my colleague from hong kong said that
there was a
there were a lot of documents which were
adopted jointly by china and
russia though i i i do not agree with
you that
uh the most bene beneficiary site was
china and that the
chinese leader xi jinping probably urged
uh vladimir putin to start this special
military operation i do not agree with
this completely so and another in the
sovereign direction uh this new uh
rapidly emerging
uh csto organization which was has been
already existed but now it is more
strength and
the caspian the caspian grouping and
also the s
co the shanghai corporation organization
because it combines china
india iran actually with the population
of more than 40 percent of the world so
this is this is good allies of russia
and russia will be
communicating with them and will be
counting on their support and will be
strengthening these groupings okay
uh teresa
the the the alliance nato itself has
been very cautious about the need to
move forward towards all the region the
australians from romania all the way to
the baltic states because they were
pretty much concerned about triggering
any incident that would unleash a
massive military confrontation with
russia but do you think that with the
invasion of ukraine
that was
the red line that was drawn by the
alliance the moment it was crossed there
was no point of return
well i think no one wants to see a nato
russia war but the fact that there has
been penetration of swedish airspace by
russian planes there has been some
russian drones going into polish
airspace you know everyone has played
this down in order not to increase the
threat level but i think that what we've
seen now with the new
nato security concept that
this is a huge concern and that
the only way now forward is better
defense not just deterrence but defense
and i think that uh
this has really demonstrated that russia
is a deep concern that hard power
is something that you know everyone just
thought we could negotiate with them
become more energy dependent on russia
have this kind of interdependence i
think all of this strategy i mean the
germans called it vandal der khandel or
their aus politi was really much really
focused on relations with russia and
that has proven to be uh put on the ash
heap of history so i think that this
idea that if we're nice to russia then
putin will be nice to us and everything
will work out well well that's been
pretty much uh
learned that that was a huge mistake so
i think the the big question now is what
is the way forward what kind of peace
exactly i don't hear anything we've been
talking about that so i think that's one
of the key uh aspects but also looking
at the bigger geopolitical picture no
one can ignore that china will become uh
or is uh something everyone needs to
keep their eye on and this also means
for the europeans it's not just
burden-sharing it's burden-shifting the
us needs europeans to spend more on
their own defense so the us can focus
more on the indo-pacific and this is
something that europeans will find
difficult because we are in an
inflationary period but security should
always trump politics and economics so
i think that's the key i see your point
uh i have few other issues to discuss uh
with you if you don't mind
andrew
are we likely to see more action as far
as the south and east china seas are
concerned
well i think that you can see that the
united states is now riding
high at least and ostensibly um on the
kind of ability to rally at the european
union
under this leadership i mean this has
never happened before under trump and
nato at the time was almost mormon but
now nato has been re-energized but
riding high on bank uh is trying to form
a global
alliance of democracies against china so
let's talk about
the g2012 or democracies uh there is
also this uh pacific um
um um infrastructure initiative uh but
then um you can see that the uh both
china and russia are starting to push
back uh i refer to the recent brits uh
summit uh
with brazil and india
and south africa tried to expand the
brics uh block as it were to include um
argentina uh and also iran um well uh uh
in addition to what's uh referred
earlier as the shanghai cooperation
organization uh the various uh
partners so i think that we can see a
growing divide between um the west and
developed countries and okay developing
world as it were but the
one one one very important point is that
the developing world according to the
oecd is going to account for six zero
percent of the world's economy by the
year 2030. so you can see that the
balance is shifting
vladimir in very few words if you don't
mind do you see potential for
reconciliation between nato and russia
uh you know yes yes despite the all the
horrible situation actually which is
now has come to existence
between
nato and russia i think
there are some crucial points of mutual
interest which to my mind
should be present in any future
relations between russia and native
countries all right this is
international terrorism and this is
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons
teresa is the is nato and europe in
particular ready for scaling up military
force and we we know what comes along
with this which is basically great
defense expenditure
well i think
president macron said just a couple
years ago that nato was brain dead so i
think that nato has come back and that
when eu member states join nato it means
that they're not really voting for eu
strategic autonomy that they prefer to
be in nato so i think that
yes this is going to cost money and it's
going to have to be prioritized but it's
there germany has pledged 100 billion to
strengthen their own military so the
1989 peace dividend is clearly finished
and countries will have to in europe
especially have to spend on their own
defense we'll have to leave it there
teresa fallon anjo long and vladimir
sotnikov i really appreciate your
insight thank you
and thank you for watching you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website
aljazeera.com for further discussion go
to our facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for
mihashimaka and the entire team here in
doha
bye for now
you